[موسيقى]
مرحبا انا مريم العاليه لنتابع معا ابرز
اخبار الاسبوع الماضي بايجاز وضمن ابرز
الاحداث
استشهاد الاسير خضر عدنان الملك تشارلز
يتوج على عرش بريطانيا استقاله الاب
الروحي للذكاء الاصطناعي واخبار اخرى
لنتابعها معا
الاسبوع الماضي قتلت قوات الاحتلال مجموعه
من الفلسطينيين منهم ناشطان نفذ عمليه في
الاغوار واثنان اتهمتهما بالمسؤوليه عن
عمليه اطلاق نار في مستوطنه ابني حفظ
اضافه الى استشهاد فتاه في حواره بزعم
قيامها بعمليه طعن في سياق متصل استشهد
الاسير خضر عدنان في سجون الاحتلال متاثرا
باضرابه عن الطعام قرابه ثلاثه اشهر ما
اثر تنديدا بسياسات الاحتلال تجاه الاسرى
وادى الى موجه تصعيد بين الاحتلال
والمقاومه في غزه قبل ان تتدخل وساطات
لوقف التصعيد استشهاد خضر عدنان اثار
تفاعلا وغضبا واسعا على المنصات لنقرا بعض
التغريدات ونبداها بتغريده لسجود محاجنه
كتبت فيها ذهب الظما وابتلت العروق وذهب
الجوع وزالت القيود وان تذيعت الحريه
ورحلت الى رضوان رب كريم باجر عظيم بينما
قال هيثم ابو حيفا شيخ المقاومه وصانع
الخبز والحريه الشيخ خضر عدنان يربح البيع
ويستشهد وحيدا في زنزانته كانه يعلمنا اخر
الدروس كما عادته الملك تشارلز ثالث يتوج
على عرش بريطانيا في حفل تاريخي كما كانت
مراسم دفن الملكه اليزابيث التي حكمت
البلاد سبعين عاما قاده ورؤساء دول حضروا
التتويج كما اصطف مئات الالاف بالقرب من
قصر باكنج هام ومحيط كنيسه
لمشاهده المراسم تقارير اعلاميه تحدثت عن
تجاوز تكاليف التتويج اكثر من 100 مليون
جنيه استرليني وهو رقم اثار الكثير من
الجدل بين البريطانيين في ظل استمرار تعطر
المدن في السودان مع السيطره على المقر
السياديه والعسكريه تحتدم في الخرطوم بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع ما ادى الى
تفاقم الاوضاع الغذائيه والطبيه اذا حضر
مسؤولون من قرب نفاذ المواد والمستلزمات
الطبيه الخاصه بمرضى غسيل الكلى بسبب قطاع
الامداد في غضون ذلك اعلنت الحكومه
السعوديه رسميا بدء المباحثات الاوليه بين
ممثل كل من الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع لمحاوله الاتفاق على وقف اطلاق
النار وانهاء الصراع لنسال زميلنا عمر
الخطيب المتخصص بشان السوداني عن اسباب
الفشل المتكرر للهدن بين الطرفين عمر
برايك لماذا تفشل الهدى في السودان طبعا
هذه هي الهدنه السابعه
التي تنهار في السودان وان كان بحده اخف
حيث اليوم رصدنا يعني مواجهات اقل اقل
عنفا مقارنه بالايام الماضيه لكن الهدن
تظل هي وسيله الجا اليها طرفي الصراع اما
لتحسين اوضاعهم على الارض او لكسب يعني
القبول من الحلفاء الدوليين لحتى لا
يسهروا بمصر من من يحبزون خيار الحرب لكن
الواقع في الارض اثبتت طوال الثلاث اسابيع
الماضيه ان
العمليات العسكريه لم تتوقف وقد ياخذ
الامر بعضا من الوقت قد نشهد المزيد من
الهدن شكرا لك يا عمر والان الى اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
روسيا اعلنت احباط هجوم بطائرتين مسيرتين
على الكرملين متهمه اوكرانيا بتمثيله
ومتوعده بالرد عليه في حين نفت اوكرانيا
اي ضلوع لها في الهجوم كما تعرضت منشاه
اليسكيا النفطيه جنوب روسيا لهجومين
بالمسيرات تسبب باندلاع حريق في المنشاه
وعلى صعيد اخر وفي تصاعد للخلاف عن
الاعلاني هاجم رئيس مجموعه فاكنار الروسيه
وزير الدفاع الروسي معلنا سحب قواته من
بخموت في غضون ايام في حين امتنع الكرملين
عن التعليق لنسال مراسلنا من اوكرانيا
تامر الصمادي عن تعاطياف مع هذا الخلاف
مرحبا تامر
حدثنا عن موقف اوكرانيا من الخلاف بين
فاجنر ووزاره الدفاع الروسيه نعم مريم
الخلافه الذي بدا واضحا بين رئيس شركه
فاجنر والقياده الروسيه العسكريه تعاملت
معه السلطات الاوكرانيه لاسيهم العسكريه
منها بشيء كبير من الشك وظهرت المتحدثه
باسم القياده العسكريه الاوكرانيه لتقول
بان هذا الخلاف قد يكون من باب الدعايه
النائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ظهرت هي
الاخرى لتقول بان القتال يتواصل بين
القوات الاوكرانيه وفاجنر في باخموت وبان
قوات باجنار تتكبد خسائر فادحه المتحدث
باسم القياده الشرقيه الاوكرانيه ظهر هو
الاخر ليقول بان حديث قائد شركه فاجنر عن
سحب قواته بسبب نقص الذخيره من بخمه ليس
دقيقا وبان السبب الحقيقي هو الخسائر او
هي الخسائر الكبيره التي يتكبدها فاغنر في
تامر الصمادي من اوكرانيا شكرا لك الاب
الروحي لذكاء الاصطناعي استقال من جوجل
بعد مسيره مهنيه استمرت عقودا من الزمن
جفره هنتن عبر عن مخاوفه المتصاعده من
الاضرار الجسيمه التي قد يسببها الذكاء
الاصطناعي مستقبلا ومن تفوقه على ذكاء
البشري وقال انه يشعر بالاسف حياله دور
الكبير الذي لعيبه في تطوير هذه
التكنولوجيا كنا سالناكم عبر تويتر عن
الذكاء الاصطناعي واذا كان برايكم يشكل
خطرا على الانسان فجاءت اجاباتكم كالتالي
نحو 72 بالمئه صوت بنعم بينما صوت سبعه
وعشرون بالمئه بلا وصلنا الى ختام هذا
الانجاز الاسبوعي نلقاكم في ايجاز الاسبوع
المقبل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]